on se retrouve pour notre dossier du
jour ce soir spécial angoulême le bilan
avec florence cestac grand prix du
festival et donc président du prochain
festival d'angoulême
pascal rabaté meilleur album de l'année
ibicus tome 2 olivier delcroix du figaro
littéraire qui est un petit peu notre
spécialiste arrêt droite rive gauche
avant de passer à nos amis l'ambiance
générale d'angoulême bon car il nous en
a un petit peu parlé mais qu'est ce
qu'on a vu de l'intérieur nous on c'est
vrai qu'en fait on en discutait un petit
peu antennes
il n'y a pas de d'endroits où on a plus
de danser cette année ça nous a pas mal
manquer moi j'ai découvert un petit lieu
un petit peu sympathique un underground
qui s'appelle l' échiquier où
effectivement on boit des bières qu'à 4
heures du matin faisant le monde c'est
très sympa c'est très creux bien décalé
marrant voulait dire que angoulême il
faut qu'il se mettre un peu au goût du
jour s'ils veulent que si elle a attiré
quelque des gens comme quoi quelque part
c'est vrai en france alors que c'est
chiant oui parce qu'il n'y a rien
d'ouvert étant obligés de chercher des
bars un peu partout et moi on a retrouvé
un moi j'allais trouver un indice à ce
point là on sentait un peu la frite ans
a réussi malefoy la can alors la balle
d'axa voilà voilà
depuis elle était condamnée à rester au
mercure on en faisait le monde dans un
cadre un petit peu sympathique mais un
petit peu formel quoi bien alors on va
passer au millésime parce que sinon
sinon je vais me faire engueuler là si
on parle que des boîtes de nuit
d'angoulême mais ça a pas l'air terrible
non les prochaines arena mozilla on
s'adresse
florence qui veut être la présidente
whistler présidence un appel tu en fis
le crabe
alors que vaut le millésime 2000 en deux
mots c'est un cru très intéressant parce
que très cohérent le millésime 2000
c'est surtout effectivement une école
une génération c'est ce que nous on
un petit peu appelé le triangle de la
ligne sombre en référence à la éclair
causé par hergé dans les années 30 puis
ensuite juste après qui a créé toute une
génération
là effectivement ça sanctionne avec
blutch qui fait donc un album prime prix
alph art humour pour blotch avec rabat
et donc ibicus tome 2 avec blain et le
réducteur de vitesse david b l'ascension
du haut mal prix du scénario on
s'aperçoit que c'est toute une école tu
fumes g ration tue tout une bande de
copains qui ont travaillé qui ont
effectivement lu tintin mais qui rend
qui ont dépassé le stade de tintin et
qui sera bien raconter les vraies
histoires ancrées dans le réel
effectivement et sans concession moi
c'est ce que j'aime cette génération
s'en sont sans concession véritable
merci merci c'est beaucoup plus clair on
va avant de parler de vous et on va
regarder un petit magnéto florence êtes
d'accord
magnéto mais c'est ce qui compte on
appelle enfin je les baptisés comme ça
c'est le style gros nez donc c'est
toujours un peu moqueur c'est à dire que
les gens voient tout de suite que ça va
être drôle qu'on ne va pas leur raconter
l'histoire triste mais j'aime bien aussi
jouer aussi avec ses personnages mais
racontée aux filles fectivement des
histoires tristes mélange de tristesse
et de rires et tristesse et bien
mélanger les deux ponts
[Musique]
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter sur
votre style
non non c'est tuer j'ai rien à dire ça
tu es payé pas longtemps ce petit
reportage mais bien et vous alors si
vous avez vu le truc qui vous ont donné
là franchement c'est pas terrible à le
alphare ça s'appelle là c'est vrai que
c'était pas on appelait ça le machin à
anvers où toutes les machines servent à
ses palais ceci dit mais bon préférez
les petits bouquets mois les alfred les
alfred oui enfin l'alfred en bon bah
ouais ou même en allumant sa donc
meilleur album de l'année un pascal
rabaté dont québec jugement encore je ne
résiste pas au plaisir vous pouvez
parler pendant que je monte ce qui t'a
vu au plaisir de se saisir de montrer
tellement c'est certain c'est un prix
qui est véritablement collange pas ce
que vous en pensez mais mais il ya une
cohérence dans le ils ont tous le même
âge ils ont ils ont tous un dessin comme
ça expressionniste c'est vrai que c'est
pareil avec christophe blain c'est
pareil avec bologne
on n'est pas tous du même âge mais je
crois que les les boules aussi bien
david b que que de christophe ou deux
blutch on a commencé à avoir un peu de
résonance en même temps mais david ça
fait dix ans qu'ils bossent l'agent de
chômage j'ai fait mes premiers bouquins
ce futur os en 89 donc jamais fait trois
là bas donc ça fait quand même 11 ans
que que je fais des bouquins non mais
quand on voit la qualité de ce que vous
dessinez puis quand on sait pas ce qu'on
en entendra tout à l'heure que pena qui
préfère faire une bd plutôt qu'un livre
pour parler de lui à cause de la
mondialisation et du du débauchage soit
là il appelle ça la débauche ça montre
que la bd capte énormément mais carlo
quelque part aussi on se rend compte
qu'il ya quand même 1055 album qui est
paru qui sont parus cette année chiffres
du chiffre d'affaires de la bande
dessinée totalement à contre-courant du
chiffre de l'édition parce que en hausse
de +3 5% c'est quand même assez
incroyable de s'apercevoir que la bande
dessinée qui a donnée pour morte dans
les années 90 tout d'un coup des dépasse
complètement le chiffre de l'édition
cette année encore le meilleur livre
toutes éditions confondues c'est une
bande dessinée c'est gaston la reddition
de gaston sept cent mille exemplaires
quentin quentin astérix or ces trois
millions d'exemplaires le tintin vous
voulez lire le livre le plus vendu en
france cette année c'est une bd bah oui
il faut il faut veiller s'est petit à
petit mais saab numéro trois c'est
alors il ya largo winch bien sûr qu est
l un des rôles doit beaucoup ben en tout
cas nous on aime on aime bien le figaro
publication de là et puis donc avec
gaston iv le petit spirou il ya eu
atteinte 1 c'est assez incroyable de
s'apercevoir que finalement la bande
dessinée autour d alain elle se porte
bien mais voilà exactement
et puis les nouveaux ils arrivent alors
les nouveaux j'adore c'est que j'ai vécu
une petite anecdote qui est qui ferment
qui vaut son pesant de moutards j'étais
à l'exposition moebius qui est
magnifique et je rencontre joan sfar est
là aussi l'un des parents monde cette
nouvelle génération de la ligne sombre
et il rencontre mevius ils se
prosternent à terre et tous à monsieur
mobius je vous adore et tout et j'ai vu
votre exposition j'en suis sorti et j'ai
eu une seule pensée je veux vous écrasez
où j'arrête les médias et les bus qui se
marrent rigole et qui dit ça alors j'ai
eu la même pensée il ya 35 ans quand je
suis arrivé devant le travail de jijé à
l'époque c'est jerry spring c'était la
bande dessinée de pap a cité les
westerns avec les chapeaux et les colts
et tout est est en fait petit à petit
cette nouvelle génération à la raison
elle a envie d'écraser l'autre et vous
avez en effet c'est avant avant de nous
pardon aux plantes voulait dire quelque
chose
quand j'étais petit je lisais le journal
de mickey est absolument puis tout faire
pour y arriver on se retrouve avec
l'écrivain daniel pennac pour la
parution de la débauche la bd qu'il
cosigne avec tardi chez futuropolis
gallimard
alors la jeunesse de l'histoire donc
c'est que vous vous avez été amené pour
des raisons familiales amicales assurer
un procès aux prud'hommes et vous avez
été saisie par l'obscénité du
licenciement voulu en faire un livre est
finalement enfin lundi oui je voulais en
faire un essai finalement j'ai opté pour
le c'est un petit peu comme si on avait
le choix entre faire un éditorial la une
du monde et un dessin de plantu
mais le dessin de plantu fait très
souvent fonction d'éditorial je trouve
que le dessin de tardi en l'occurrence
m'a permis de cogner plus fort que si
j'avais écrit un essai c'est fort alors
tardy c'est votre ami vous êtes voisin
oui à belleville à vous déjeunez un
dimanche chez vous un dimanche chez lui
il sert narac
et alors si c'était commence à frétiller
de longues années d'abord débuté pour
géo je crois qu'ils avaient du string de
vos nouvelles oui mais oui il ya une
quinzaine d'années il a illustré une
nouvelle pour eux géo ensuite on a fait
un petit conte pour info contes pour
enfants qui mêle le sens de la
houppelande ensuite il a fait les les
couvertures des malaussène puis tout au
tout les livres de poche
après les photos c'est lui qui fait
découvrir et moi je connaissais de toute
façon son travail avant de le connaître
lui aussi alors le titre donc c'est la
débauche évidemment c'est le contraire
de l' embauche normalement débauchage
voilà le débauchage mais effectivement
il ya un jeu de mots faille en double
sens qui met bien en valeur je dirais la
la débauche du système libéral quoi oui
c'est l'obscénité avec laquelle les
entreprises pour économiser des
indemnités décourage les gens en les
humiliant et avec donc des
intermédiaires chargés de cette
humiliation en l'occurrence ici dans
cette bande dessinée un drh mais ça peut
aussi bien être des collègues ça peut
aussi bien et la désolidarisation
général qui fait qu'un individu est
petit à petit nier
amoindri humilié n'est plus lui même et
perd tout ressort y compris celui de se
retourner contre l'entreprise dans une
forme de totalitarisme d'une certaine
façon alors soft oui c'est un assassinat
social ou le lait quand assassiné mais
physiquement il arrête réel assassinat
social qui peut aboutir à l'assassinât
tout court puisque quand même le nombre
de suicides n'est pas négligeable en fin
de parcours alors c'est qu'ici vous
savez pas mais on dit le pitch heures le
pitch c'est de résumer le livre ans
qu'elle est voilà donc l on pourrait
dire ces scandales au jardin des plantes
alors il ya lilic et médecin chef justin
est un flic sympa avec qui elle vit un
jour en passant devant une cage il voit
un type qui a écrit homo sapiens
l'abhorré 40 européenne ue c'est à dire
homo sapiens au chômage
freeman travail privé travaillant type
hirsute qu'est ce qui se passe c'est un
type qui est en cash dont quatre ans
s'est engagé un chômeur apparemment qui
s'est mis en cage pour attirer
l'attention et il attire effectivement
la tension avec la télévision va le
filmer pendant 10 jours jusqu'au moment
où lily qui en a par dessus la tête qui
est humilié pour lui langen lui un
manque une engueulade terrifiante et le
lendemain de cette engueulade
on le retrouve pendu ouais c'est à dire
que voilà c'était d'abord il ya la télé
qui vient il ya une phrase mais que j'ai
piqué dans votre [ __ ] c'est le type
de la télé l'a un peu genre elle s'est
un peu kane et qui dit la trop
simplicité de ce spectacle dé toute la
tragédie du chômage dans ce genre de
phrase et la journée quand quand on les
lit comme ça mais oui des colis seront
contactés côté met à plat et qu'on les
met à plat on se rend compte que c'est
terrible effectivement pendant une
semaine ce chômeur en cage devient un
phénomène de société et un soin
l'interpellent lui dit la télé vous à
bouffer vous avez fait qu'ouvrir le
robinet à trémolos et le chemin en catch
c'est le rêve des patrons et ça a été
filmé et ça a été filmé l asm ce qu'il y
avait des caméras à l'intérieur des
cages là je sais tout ça était préparé à
l'avancé
elle ne s'en rend pas compte et l'homme
à sa passe évidemment aux écrans et le
type retrouvé pendu ouais donc
évidemment elles étaient les ailes et
elle va être soupçonné alors dû à la
suite d'un land art est là on arrête là
alors bon est ce que vous croyez que la
culture est le dernier rempart contre la
cette espèce que vous appelez en face
qu'on appelle la globalisation la
mondialisation parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'artistes
dans tous les domaines d'ailleurs
effectivement qui prennent la parole là
dessus alors que les politiques
finalement on dirait qu'ils ont tout
abandonné quoi moi je ne pense pas que
la culture est soit un an par soit une
arme ne sait pas par hasard que les
premiers à se faire zigouiller en
période d'insurrection militaires par
exemple sont les intellectuels les
chanteurs les artistes etc
donc je crois qu'en tout cas nous sommes
là pour nous sommes là quand je dis nous
c'est vraiment au sens très large
les saltimbanques pour rendre compte de
notre perception du monde
alors on va parler de votre association
parce qu'il se trouve que justement
aller elle est culturelle
c'est une association qui s'appelle lire
et faire lire donc vous demander à des
retraités qui dit d'aller lire des
livres à des enfants
ben oui c'est tout à fait simple et
c'est vrai qu'à une époque on vivait
tous ensemble en famille c'était naturel
et aujourd'hui compte tenu de ce qui est
devenu la famille faut l'organiser
oui c'est ainsi on s'est aperçu que les
enfants arrivent en sixième avait un
niveau de lecture qui n'étaient pas
satisfaisants et un instituteur breton a
eu l'idée de faire venir des retraités
et de recréer ce rapport calme en ce
rapport de du grand-père qui lit le soir
aux enfants entendants et ça a très bien
marché et donc
une association s'est créée qui
s'appelle lire et faire lire et qui
décide de faire ça sur l'ensemble du
territoire français sur l'ensemble des
départements français donc des retraités
peuvent aller dans des écoles primaires
à l'invitation d'instituteurs lira des
enfants il y à un numéro de téléphone
donné nationale je vais vous les
instituteurs peuvent appeler et les
retraités peuvent appeler voilà alors
c'est une association qui est parrainée
par 110 écrivain c'est le numéro
téléphone notez le bien si vous êtes
soit avait un enfant qui veut lire ou un
vous êtes retraité vous voulez lire aux
enfants
08 25 83 28 33 08 25 83 28 33 voilà
finalement est ce que est ce que vous
dites on en revient à ce que disais tout
à l'heure est ce que on peut donner un
coup d'arrêt à ce que vous appelez la
débauche c'est à dire vous dit sinon il
y aura une réaction violente et à ça si
je sais pas ce qu'on peut faire
institutionnellement ça veut dire que
quand on a une société comme la nôtre
qui ne produit plus rien que des
services ou le l'argent n'est que le
fruit de ses propres dividendes et où
dans le même temps les gens de moins en
moins de travail
je ne sais pas si des artistes peuvent
tenter quelque chose
mais ce que je crois c'est qu'à
l'intérieur des entreprises les gens ne
peuvent pas s'exonérer de comportement
personnel c'est-à-dire que quand on voit
si je vous vois vous vous faire lourder
de façon absolument inadmissible faut
que j'intervienne
il n'y a pas d'autre solution je vous
connais la pression va conduire à de la
télé non mais c'est plaisant
il n'y a pas de on ne peut pas ne pas
intervenir au moins dans le cadre où les
choses se passent immédiatement ce qui a
donné un chèque avant il y avait la
révolution et le mouvement syndical il y
avait des partis de gauche etc
mais maintenant les gens sont devenus
tellement individualiste et vous dites
vous-même d'ailleurs vous dit un jour on
n'est pas à l'abri qu'à un mec qui pète
les plombs et qui tire dans le tas bien
sûr ce que la révolte s'est
individualise
ce sera dramatique il vaut finalement
beaucoup mieux une descente général dans
la rue que des types rendu à ce point
malheureux qui deviennent complètement
fou et se met s'enferme dans des cas je
viens aujourd'hui mes plantes
alors ce plan politique bon vous êtes de
gauche mais vous dites vous êtes revenu
de tous les points d'exclamation en
forme de poteaux d'exécution et la
gauche aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est dsk
strauss kahn c'est bourdieu sur le plan
politique je crois au comportement
encore une fois vraiment au comportement
personnel individuel que ce soit dans
son immeuble dans son entreprise
finalement je suis vieille hautement
moralisme mais je crois de se dire je
crois dur comme fer je peux toujours
énoncé des principes on peut toujours
faire mais je n'entends concessionnaires
d'un comportement en ce moment en soi
même c'est facile de se faire valoir
ça c'est pas trop difficile d'en parler
à la télé mieux c'est l'action
quotidienne on enchaîne avec notre coup
d'oeil sur le président du jury
d'angoulême robert cramer le brueghel ba
ba de la bd est ici portraiturer par ses
deux collègues et disciple dupuy et
berberian karine roy a filmé de l'art et
des coachs en magnétos grand prix à
l'unanimité d'angoulême 99 et présidente
27e festival et la bande dessinée le
créateur de frites de quatre l'américain
robert crumb est amis de la bd en
demandent mais aussi un président très
contesté
reconnu comme l'un des plus grands
dessinateurs de notre époque preuve
d'une timidité maladive il n'a accordé
quasiment aucune interview n'est pas
venue chercher son prix lors de la
cérémonie
c'est son éditeur qui a pris la parole à
sa place ceux parmi vous qui connaissent
mon travail et ont lu mes histoires
savent à quel point la foule me fait
peur et à quel point je n'aime pas les
micros et la lumière des projecteurs
qu'on excuse ma franchise et se
retrouver seul sur une scène de théâtre
aveuglés par les projecteurs n'est pas
précisément l'idée que je me fais de
bons moments quand on remerciera le jury
d'angoulême à sa façon en donnant un
concert acoustique soutenu par son
groupe de world music et primitifs du
futur
[Musique]
et
enfant battu kremlin trop vers qui se
sert de la bande dessinée comme exutoire
c'est son seul rapport au monde il
transpose avec jenny tous ses fantasmes
les plus trash dans les années 60-70
l'avant d'une nouvelle manière de
dessiner en se shootant au lsd quand
même dit que le sait le dessin de la
sauver sa vie c'est vraiment pas de la
rigolade
dupuy et berberian prix du meilleur
album l'année dernière pour monsieur
jean sont des admirateurs
inconditionnels pour les dessinateurs
d'aujourd'hui sont tous des rejetons de
robert cran tous les grand prix
d'angoulême ont une reconnaissance
profonde vis-à-vis de cramant tant que
dessinateur et des gens comme comme les
bus comme moi comme bon gotlib on l'a
déjà dit vraiment on est allés boire à
cette source se casse à sa manière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
souvent j'ai entendu des jambes réduire
crom a un côté pipi caca comme ça très
très ras des pâquerettes aller simple
pour un truc de boutonneux
et puis ça ça va pas plus loin que ça
mais non ça c'est pas vrai c'est
vraiment un travail très profond et est
un travail d'écrivain en plus c'est
quelqu'un qui a une réflexion sur sa vie
qui qui vient d'intégrer son travail
dans sa vie pour avancer limite pour
pouvoir justement dans l'expo là c'est
vraiment pour moi dessine alors ça me
déprime arrive jamais à ce niveau c'est
pas possible
merci karine roy on se retrouve après
les pubs pour la suite de ce best of est
notre agenda du week-end programmée par
mes amis de toujours
on continue avec notre coup de coeur
pour les space invaders ces aliens
protéiforme et pixellisée qui squattent
nos murs nos trottoirs où nos statuts
s'affirme comme le nouvel art de la rue
christophe s'en donnait pas rester de
marbre magnéto scruter les coins et
recoins de l'espace urbain les murs et
parfois même les monuments attention
dans la rue l'invasion des hors-la-loi
dollar a déjà commencé
bravant police et justice ils
envahissent de plus en plus
obsessionnellement notre show visuel
mais y sont anonymes en deux grandes
solitaire et sauvage
[Musique]
heureusement dans un document vidéo
exclusif envoyé à la rédaction le plus
connu est omniprésent de ces artistes de
rue le mystérieux imad heures me dévoile
la basse besogne et l'humour troisième
degré de ses bienfaits artistique et me
donnent des indices pour le retrouver
un amateur de jeux de piste je suis une
veille d'heure je suis responsable de
l'invasion de la terre par l'ex patineur
là le propre des spéciaux meyers d'être
fabriquée en carrelage carrelage de
salle de bains mosaïque piscine
n'importe quoi donc c'est carré est
solide
ensuite sont fixés avec du ciment de la
colle c'est une créature qui est déjà
pixelisé à la base qui sont très vieux
jeu vidéo
il ya une très faible résolution bizarre
non
l'espèce meilleur sur les monuments qui
tiennent le mieux presque plus que sur
des murs privé donc je remercie presque
les autorités
sur la cassette pirate je découvre
également de ce qui a créé avec l'hymne
vedder le collectif anonymous
une autre personnalité de l'art de rue
qui le visage toujours masqué d'un ba
dessine à la peinture blanche des
silhouettes à même le sol
c'est vrai qu'il ya de plus en plus de
gens qu'on intervienne dans l'espace
urbain
c'est un petit peu une tendance actuelle
je pense que l'originalité de la
démarche avant tout à ses d'utiliser
autre chose que les bombes de peinture
en france les principales villes dont
ces paris bien sûr grenoble-montpellier
je prépare je travaille sur marseille
amsterdam
londres barcelone en vers tokyo los
angeles
mais comment retrouver l'insaisissable
invaders aujourd'hui courtisé par les
milieux branchés de l'art contemporain
de la haute couture
je vais rodez du côté de chez almine
rech une galeriste qui embarque les
space invaders pour la foire d'art
contemporain de new york
régulière s'est pas vu depuis et je fais
un projet avec lui une exposition pour
le 29 avril à quoi il ressemble à ça je
peux pas vous le dire personne n'a
jamais vu son visage c'est pas un petit
indice pour moi quand je le retrouve oui
il sera à l'aéroport aujourd'hui avec
une grosse valise noire du côté du
concept store jean charles de
castelbajac un grand fan de l'artiste on
me confirme l'info le couturier a même
financé son plan d'invasion de paris un
côté piraté à côté sulfureux mais il ya
aussi un côté très élaborés et très
stratégique et conceptuel moi je pense
que
que la russie la plus belle galerie le
monde dont les pilotes passent et c'est
comme ça que j'ai connus keith haring
c'est devenu mon ami c'est comme ça j'ai
connu jean michel basquiat invaders et
bien les reports en partance pour new
york
j'arrive enfin à intercepter le
hors-la-loi dollar puis un petit peu en
pleine conquête territoriale en ce
moment on lâcherait dans quelques heures
à new york et en californie la semaine
dernière et ça va continuer comme ça
pendant un petit moment
le mot de la fin
allez merci christophe sand au jeu
reçoit maintenant le philosophe bernard
henri lévy pour la parution chez grasset
de son essai le siècle de sartre alors
votre livre bon bah c'est la thèse des
deux sartre donc c'est le coeur du coeur
du livre avant le stalag et après le
stalag alors avant d'en distant dahlia
voir nietzschéen vous dites découvreur
du vaccin anti totalitaire et après
après le stalag donc après la guerre
admirateur de staline
en tous les cas quand on pleure pas
quand on te remets tueur et faire de lui
à cette union soviétique entre les deux
il ya eu stalag et là vous dites qu'il
devient humaniste il découvre il devient
progressiste tu découvres l'homme avec
un grand h est pour vous enfin c'est
votre interprétation en tous les cas
celle de votre livre c'est le coeur du
problème c'est cette espèce de
renversement du personnage
moi je crois en gros si vous voulez pour
aller très vite mais contrairement à
l'idée dominante à l'idée reçue
je crois que tant que sartre mais ça
dépasse le cas de sartre c'est vrai
d'autres écrivains au xxème siècle tant
que sartre et anti humaniste c'est à
dire tant qu'ils ne croient pas encore
aux grandes idéologies progressif sur
l'avenir de l'homme sur la construction
d'un homme nouveau radieux et ses îles
et démocrates
le jour où il devient humaniste c'est à
dire quand il commence à entrer
à accorder son crédit à la fable d'un
homme de meilleure qualité
alors il ya les dérapages que nous
savons sur lui c'est vous que ça tant
qu'héritier totalité il tente
antitotalitaire quand ils anti humaniste
et quand est ce que je crois que quand
il est intime à nice tu y crois à
l'individu au sujet il croit pas à
l'homme majuscule et puis en revanche
quand il devient humaniste alors ils
croient à une seule espèce humaine
réconcilier enfin ils croient mais c'est
pas oui c'est une croyance voir et
surtout ses passes hearts et je crois
que c'est de l'histoire du 20e siècle ça
alors effectivement il découvre la
liberté avant le stalag et après il
libre oui c'est bien mais pour quelque
chose faite pour quelque chose on va
essayer pour rien voilà c'est très clair
et c'est un des thèmes des chemins de la
liberté d c'est un des thèmes qui qui
anime ce ce grand lire ce monument
littéraire que sont les chemins de
liberté alors là il commence à dire
à se planter quoi c'est à dire les deux
pas sur plein de conneries quoi c'était
les deux d'abord souligner les
dénonciateurs du régime soviétique donc
david rousset il dit on ne répond pas
david rousset on lui laisse gagner sa
vie comme il peut c'est sous les chances
des total ce qui est plutôt drôle
il ya les deux yassa et puis en même
temps au moment par exemple de la
hongrie en 56 un texte admirable qui
s'appelle le fantôme de staline qui est
un texte anti stalinien d'une fiole
c'est encore pire si vous le dira s'il
est capable de dire tout et son
contraire en même temps ou à un an
d'intervalle est capable lorsque les
chars entrent alors en hongrie il est
capable de dire son horreur il est
capable de dire oui d'accord mais nathan
empêche son mépris pour les communistes
ont imaginé imaginez un type qui soit
arrivée en 42 à paris et qui ai dit fais
les camps de concentration les les camps
de la mort
et puis quand le fpi que l'on ai dit en
parlant de ce type là on ne répond pas à
ce type là on lui laisse gagner sa vie
comme il peut je veux dire kravtchenko
j'ai choisi la liberté sont sont les
traités d'agents de la cia comme vous
d'ailleurs parlé par les communistes et
il fait un procès au pc et sartre
même s'il a conscience que 35 audi pas
complètement pas complètement tort il le
laisse se faire lyncher par garcia de
l'époque
non mais d'abord il d'abord je crois
qu'il faut pas tout mélanger et quel que
soit moi j'ai écrit il ya 20 ans annick
c'est pas la barbarie à visage humain
juste et je ne suis donc pas suspect a
la moindre complaisance à l'endroit de
ceux qui ont pu couvrir les crimes
staliniens
n'empêche qu'on ne peut pas comparer je
reprends vos termes les camps de la mort
avec les crimes staliniens ces deux
choses différentes
premièrement deuxièmement c'est vrai que
sartre a dit par exemple en 54 la
liberté de critiquer total en urs c'est
vrai alors il ya deux celui ci l'a dit
un anticommuniste est un chien jeunes en
jeu ne sort pas de là je m'en sortirais
jamais un argument il faut essayer de
comprendre pourquoi moi j'ai écrit 675
bages pour essayer de comprendre comment
ce type formidable
cet homme libre ce théoricien de la
liberté ce mets ta fille
ce philosophe anti fasciste parce que je
crois que s'il ya un philosophe anti
fasciste au 20e siècle et anti
totalitaire c'est ça s'il ya quelqu'un
qui armera vos enfants et les miens pour
penser l'antitotalitarisme demeure sous
quelques villes
âge qu'ils prennent c'est la fille de
rielle et vous comment expliquer que cet
homme-là qui a inventé cette philosophie
là qui a inventé tous les vaccins tous
les antidotes comment expliquer qu'en
effet il est plus de leurs choses
pareilles il ya plusieurs explications
j'en donne en gros gens donnent trois ma
femme il ya 600 pages en effet ya cette
histoire de stalag c'est à dire la
découverte de la communauté l'idée en
hobereau que c'est mieux d'être membre
d'une collectivité d'un groupe que
d'être un individu il ya deuxièmement un
désespoir philosophique le désespoir
philosophique d'un homme qui était parti
avec l'idée qu'ils allaient sortie qu'il
allait en gros démentir eagle démentir
l'idée de la fin de l'histoire et de la
fin des philosophies recommencer à la
philosophie à 0 ça c'est l'être et le
néant
et puis qui se rencontrent pour des
raisons dans le détail desquels on va
pas entrer ici que cette entreprise est
vouée à l'échec
et puis là troisièmement une histoire
qui commence avec le surréalisme et qui
finit avec lui et qui a rapport avec ce
que j'appelle l'adieu à la littérature
et ça c'est l'histoire des moba aurait
vu alors bon non seulement il s'en prend
aux gens qui dénoncent l horreur
soviétique mais enfin il admire castro
mao il déteste de gaulle dit-il autant
que pétain dans la tête dans les damnés
de la terre la préface
ils appellent aux meurtres des européens
l'explication moi qui me semble la plus
claire dans toutes celles que vous avez
effectivement c'est la haine de soi mais
c'est à dire finalement cette espèce de
complexe éternelle que face à la classe
ouvrière qui est d'édifier on n'est pas
grand chose quoi mais c'est compliqué la
haine de soi observe en effet la zone
chèrement de sider oui dans le cas de
d'abord balayer aussi des explications
prosaïque il faut pas les oublier non
plus
quand il écrit la préface aux damnés de
la terre il faut voir aussi dans quelles
circonstances
on se trouve guerre d'algérie torture
d'état à grande échelle des dizaines
sans doute des centaines de corps
d'algériens jetés à la seine est
assassiné par la police française et par
le préfet papon
c'est dans cet état de rage et de colère
face à un état qui est en train de
réinventer des méthodes que l'on croyait
d'oublier que sartre écrit c'est pas une
excuse
en effet on ne comprend rien à ce genre
de texte et à cette espèce de folie qui
s'empare de lui de démence parce qu'il
ya de la démence si on oublie cela et
puis il ya une autre chose ça c'est vrai
c'est la haine de soi la haine du
bourgeois en soit la haine de l'européen
en soit ce sentiment était que pardon je
vous coupe mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
cette explication je crois que c'est
aaron qui disait il s'est pas engagée
par la guerre alors il s'est engagé
après bon mais ça c'est pas vrai place
mais c'est moi et sa bible mais ça comme
vous le savez je le démens c'est
justement voilà c'est le seul chapitre
proprement biographique de ce livre qui
n'est pas une biographie là je crois que
c'est une infamie sartre a commis plein
d'erreurs mais pas celle là encore
apparentes
il s'est bien conduit on va parler de la
guerre donc pendant la guerre il écrit
dans comedia alors évidemment il n'a pas
fait de textes collaborationniste
parfait elle a quand même écrit dedans
ils dénient fait jouer les mouches
devant un parterre d'officiers analysons
mais non non non non non non il fait
jouer les mouches devant la jeunesse de
paris devant des donc des officiers
nazis quelques temps la jeunesse de
paris devant alexandre astruc devant
jean duvignaud devant moins jeunes jean
paulhan qui sort de là en disant j'ai vu
la première pièce avec un visa d'or j'ai
vu la première pièce anti vichyste de
l'occupation c'était un peu anti dans
titre de leur histoire à un ps comme
vous dites mais palpable
enfin vous effectivement les témoins les
jeunes gens qui vont voir cette pièce
sorte galvanisé de cette représentation
jean cavaillès quand il lit l'être et le
néant qui est probablement le dernier
livre qu'il ait lu avant de saluer les
autres noms il était déjà engagé dans la
résistance
mais c'est un des derniers livres qu'il
est lui dans sa vie et on peut donc
imaginer qu'il y ait puisé d d d d un
renfort philosophique d'un master ii
vous dites moi ya une phrase comme de
vous
vraiment je suis content de pouvoir vous
en parler en face vous dites depuis
quand on reproche temps aux gens de
n'être pas des héros quand ils ont dix
ares pendant la guerre il a fait de la
résistance un peu à la noire s'était pas
il a un grand résistant c'est clair vous
dit
depuis qu'on reproche t-on aux gens de
n'être pas des héros enfin séduit henri
amouroux ça non tomassi henri amouroux y
passe son temps à dire nous c'est les
français pendant la guerre c'est
terrible il pouvait pas tous est
résistant le glaive le bouclier on va
presser henri amouroux
mais je connais rien brouille il ya deux
choses différentes dire en effet faire
l'impasse sur ce qu'a été réellement
l'occupation sur la réalité du vichysme
c'est une chose
accuser un intellectuel en l'occurrence
sarthe d'avoir été d'avoir eu la moindre
connivence d'esprit ou d'actes avec un
régime qui n'a cessé de combattre dès le
premier jour en est une autre et c'est
dégueulasse
le première chose j'en ai marre de le
répéter jeu ça fait plusieurs fois
premier jour où il attendait on vous a
connu bernard on vous a connu plus
procureur mois dans la barbarie
française dans l'idéologie française on
va connu plus procureur je me suis dit
mais lui il était à l'école à uriage
l'école des cadres mishima chat je pense
que votre mairie a eu en agissent lui
vaut beaucoup pensent que beuve méry à
uriage à alimenter la machine
idéologique du pétainisme me verrier
d'autres titres et comme il était patron
d'une récolte en école gioria ge l'école
d'uriage fabriquer du pétainisme est
fabriqué de l'idéologie mais avouez
classera - procureur mais je lui cela
mais je suis tout autant
idéologiquement sarthe fabrique une
philosophie de la liberté est une
philosophie de résistance l'être et le
néant c'est une philosophie de
résistants à tort mais comment mettre
d'accord alors c'est le contraire du
riage deuxièmement le première chose
qu'il fait à peine débarqué à paris
je veux même pas m'énerver parce que
c'est tellement évident c'est de créer
un groupe de résistance qui s'appelle
socialiste et libéral gens qui se
connaissaient dans les bistrots pour
créer des groupes de résistance et il ya
plein de gens qui se réunissent dans les
bistrots pour créer des groupes de
résistance et qui finissait sous les
coulées sous la torture de la gestapo y
compris dans le groupe sartre j'ai quand
je dis qu'on ne peut pas reprocher à un
homme de ne pas avoir été un héros jeudi
au surtout qu'on peut pas lui reprocher
de pas être mort sous la torture ya les
camarades de sartre qui sont morts sous
la torture en déportation et qui n'en
n'ont fait ni plus ni moins que lui on
se retrouve pour notre dossier du jeu
ce soir que reste-t-il de sartre avec
tout lansman directeur des temps
modernes et bien non il évite auteurs du
siècle de sartre aux éditions grasset
que finalement les prises de position de
sartre à l'époque de la guerre froide
pour moi le disqualifie bon non bernard
il est midi oui j'ai trompé m'enfin
c'est pas grave moi je dis qu'il ya des
gens qui ont été disqualifiés par leur
colle à mon avis il ya des gens qui sont
disqualifiés par leur collaborationnisme
avec l'urss de staline que je les 100
millions de gens rien c'est infiniment
plus compliqué expliqué nous et sartre
lui même d'ailleurs a écrit là-dessus il
a parlé sur sur le goût de l'époque en
disant que l'époque a toujours tort
quand elle est morte mais qu'elle a
raison quand elle est vivante et que ça
c'est un goût de l'époque je ne sais pas
quel âge vous aviez vous aviez 149 web
alors donc en 1950 vous aviez un an
absolument alors je vous donnais juste
le jour 1 de l'école ne le connaissais
pas le goût de l'effort
on sait c'est bien plus compliqué que ça
moi j'ai des jeunesses communistes
en 1943 eux et je suis rentré dans la
résistance à ce moment là et tous ept
est profondément lié à stalingrad et à
ce genre de choses et des russes était
quand même en train de nous sauver des
nazis qu'on le veuille ou non il
faudrait quand même pas vrai ça payé ça
et n'oubliez pas non plus que entre la
guerre froide commence très tôt la
guerre froide commence dès 1948 et la
guerre froide c'est quelque chose là
c'est effrayant avec la guerre de corée
très vite et que tout ça va très tout ça
est très rapide il ya une sorte de
catapultage du temps moi j'ai connu ça
en trombe 1950 deux des communistes et
la paix ça date de cinquante deux et
quatre ans plus tard en 56 affres écrit
ce texte selon bernard henri lévy a
parlé ce très beau texte le front tohme
des salines alors ne dites pas qu'il
acceptait tout c'est pas vrai il était
par dont il était traité lui même à ce
moment là par les communistes comme un
chien il les traitait de hyènes
dactylographes n'oubliez pas ça avant de
passer la parole à la parole à bernard
henri lévy je dis bien je répète ce que
j'ai dit c'est à dire que c'est un peu
ce que je reprochais à bernard tout à
l'heure dans son bouquin c'est à dire
que vous trouvez tous à sare des
circonstances atténuantes rhin vous
c'est normal mais non mais je me suis
aussi dans ce sens mais tout le monde
s'est trompé y en a marre de ces noirs
on peut dire ça des gens moi je ne
défends pas moi j'aime défendre lui même
je ne défend pas ses collaborateurs
je dis simplement qu'on peut qu on peut
l'expliquer par l'époque aussi généreux
vous nous dites l'époque c'était faut
comprendre l'époque machin mais on
pourrait dire moi je ne défends pas ces
gens là on pourrait dire que finalement
en 42 c'était l'époque aussi c'est ça
que je ne vois pas pourquoi il ya des
gens qui seraient absoudre est pas des
gens qui ne seraient pas aptes sous le
nom de l'époque ces journées bien qu'on
m'explique mois dernier
personne ne parle d'absoudre
on n'est pas au tribunal est en tout cas
moi je n'ai pas écrit un livre de
procureur on peut faire le procès mais
c'est une autre démarche pourquoi je ne
dis pas qu'il faut absurde les erreurs
sont les erreurs évidemment deuxièmement
quand on apprécie ce genre de question
est ce qu'un type s'est trompé ou non il
ya deux principes qu'il faut avoir
présent à l'esprit
premier principe ce que l'on appelle le
goût de l'époque et que moi j'appelle la
teneur en brume on juge toujours une
situation dans la clarté postérieur la
clarté futur alors qu'elle s'est vécu
dans le brouillard donc il faut essayer
d'imaginer les acteurs dans le
brouillard
l'autre principe en revanche et c'est
vrai qu'il faut pondérer les deux c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui malgré le
brouillard
en effet par une espèce d'instinct ou de
grâce et c'est arrivé à sartre souvent
voit juste exemple la guerre d'algérie
aaron contrairement à ce qu'on croit se
trompent
aaron ne et bien sûr pour l'indépendance
de l'algérie
mais pour les raisons que vous savez
c'est à dire il dit en gros il faut que
l'algérie soit indépendante parce que la
france a plus les moyens de se payer une
colonie le colonialisme j'ai rien contre
mais on n'a plus les moyens trop charger
ça coûte trop cher car éléments
d'artillerie sont améliorées une
artérite hyper ce fils d'un quai sartre
en revanche pour le coup avec une espèce
d'instinct sûr parce qu'il se range ce
coup là aux côtés d d un compte et aux
côtés des vrais d'années aux côtés des
victimes
il voit juste et idy la torture est
insupportable un régime loue un régime
fondé sur la torture n'a aucune excuse
donc dans certains cas il ya des gens
qui veulent enterrer les deux principes
le brouillard et la grâce c'est les deux
choses et parfois camus a eu raison dans
certains cas et c'est vrai que face au
totalitarisme soviétique
gloire à camus qui a été l'un des
premiers en revanche sur l'algérie
je pense qu'il a eu des zones d'opacité
où le brouillard lent pour imaginer une
troisième voie vous savez bien que ce
n'est pas là pour parler de cas le oui
moi je
il m'est arrivé pendant la guerre
d'algérie de poser à ça ce genre de
questions il disait il écrivait nous
torturons et je lui disais pourquoi est
ce que vous dites toujours nous quand
vous parlez d
des [ __ ] que vous que vous dénoncez
c'est vrai j'ai direct de les autres
auraient dit il torture d'un ferry
reprenait tout ça à son propre compte
bon et c'est ça véritablement le contenu
de de son humanisme
à ce moment là on se retrouve après les
pubs pour la suite de ce best of est
notre agenda du week-end programmée par
mes amis de toujours
chers amis chers ennemis re re
interviews débats reportages retrouver
le meilleur des infos du mercredi en fin
d'émission noter sur votre agenda
nos rendez-vous du week-end stabilo boss
et par mes amis de toujours
je reçois maintenant le comédien michel
piccoli pour la sortie en salles de
compagne de voyage j'ai regardé un petit
peu votre vie parce que je sais que vous
veniez aujourd'hui dont je regardais un
petit peu comment qui vous étiez en fait
parce que moi je vis avec vous depuis de
longues années puisque je premier film
de vous que j'ai vu c'était le mépris en
63 ans avait 14 ans donc je me suis dit
mais qui sait alors j'ai regardé alors
effectivement vos parents étaient
étaient déjà dans fin votre père était
violoniste aux concerts colonne et votre
mère était pianiste elle rêvait d'être
artiste mais la feuille de son propre
père à elle l'avait emmené fia l'avait
amené finalement à donner des leçons de
piano pour survivre et on peut dire
qu'elle souffrait de ce type en silence
non on lui se fait partie de cette
génération d'enfants de bourgeoisie très
riche qui naissent étant le douzième de
la famille et et
les conditions financières de la famille
sont un pas terrible quoi alors elle
disait qu'elle reste à la maison pour
s'occuper de vous elle vous le reprocher
un petit peu d'être obligé de rester à
la maison à cause de vous non elle me
reproche est pas moi je suis ni de mon
frère oui vous êtes las de vote
voilà quand j'avais un frère qui est
mort à l'âge de trois ans et je suis
persuadé d'après les dires de ma mère
est l'histoire de ma mère et mon
histoire et notre histoire à tous les
deux que s'il n'était pas mort elle ne
m'aurait pas conçus à huy allez donc
vous êtes né un peu comme un
remplacement complètement emplacement
nous est un problème et enfin un
problème ligne un rapport et votre mère
jus de gréco qui était votre seconde
femme disait il ya deux ans est une
énigme en lui au sujet de son enfance en
parlant de vous des comptes à régler
avec sa mère non ben oui il ya toujours
des comptes à régler avec ses parents et
où avec sa mère bien sûr j'avais des
comptes à régler l'ennui c'est que je ne
sais pas agréé avant sa mort ah ouais
mais ça c'est une forme de pudeur de
timidité que j'avais vis-à-vis d'elle et
qu'elle avait vis-à-vis de moi mais
c'est pas pour ça que j'étais un enfant
un peu sérieux un peu renfermé un peu
rébarbatif non mais silencieux et ne
voulant pas se confier ne voulant pas se
raconter
c'est ça je vais pas faire la
psychanalyse le bistrot mais c'est
intéressant de savoir que voilà à de
voir comment pourquoi vous êtes comme ça
finalement vous dites je me suis libéré
quand j'ai fait le métier métier
d'acteur finalement que tous les acteurs
disent quoi un lyonnais qui sent qu'on
rencontre ouais mais là si j'étais
courageux et prétentieux j'ai créé un
livre sur comment je me suis
psychanalyse et à travers les
personnages que j'ai joué ah oui mais ça
c'est pas un type sur moi et sur moi et
sur les personnages que j'ai joué et sur
les auteurs qui ont écrit ces
personnages alors la deuxième ya ce côté
un peu renfermé et piano il ya votre
côté révolté votre côté militant alors
je me suis dit mais d'où ça vient j'ai
trouvé une épisode de vos dilemmes dire
si ça vient de là à l'âge de 13 ans et
donc c'est l'exode un votre mère vous
donne une bicyclette 300 francs et vous
envoie comme ça seul sur la route à
l'âge de 13 ans en corrèze coûté heureux
d'y aller d'ailleurs très heureux il
abat pour la première fois quand vous
arrivez voyait pour la première fois un
homme pleurait et vous demandez pourquoi
on vous dit
juifs et là vous vous prenez ça vous
révolte évidemment vous prenez
conscience des cils et mais vous savez
quand on a 13 ans 14 ans ou entre disons
entre vin des coteaux des petits petits
ou pas encore bien grand il ya des
événements dans l'existence qui peuvent
marquer bouleversé toute votre vie mais
on ne le découvre qu'après que longtemps
après et c'est vrai que j'avais 14 ans
je venais de faire l'exode avec tous les
gens qui mouraient qui pleurait etc
et puis mais c'était le plus beau jour
de ma vie c'était un film de clément
j'étais tout seul sur la bicyclette ou
non pleurer moi je me faufilais très
bien j'arrive dans un pays de paix à la
campagne et d'autres réfugiés comme moi
et je vois un vieillard de 40 ans ouais
keep lafleur alors après voulait faire
de la résistance mais vos parents sont
avertis par un boutiquier à qui vous en
parler à vous connaissez des shows il
vous boucle à la maison ça c'est votre
seul exploit vous dites enfin vous dites
ça vous dit c'est d'avoir distribué des
photos de de gaulle lui c'est parce que
vous aviez quand même 7 cette volonté
déjà de militer de résister de militer
oui parce que grâce aux grandes
personnes et quelques ailes je vivais
qui était très accroché au poste de
radio à galen g pas quoi j'ai entendu
live comme on dit l'appel du général
dames en arrivant j'avais 13 ans mais
qu'entend l'otan à monsieur qui soit le
général de gaulle ou tartempion qui vous
dit venez combattre il faut sauver votre
pays l'un des héros et ben non
ouais bah oui il y en a qui sont
fragiles a juré y en a qui ont dit non
il y en a qui ont du coup été le
discours de l'autre bah oui mais
j'aurais entendu discours de l'eau je
sais bien voyez mais j'ai heureusement
j'ai séparé le mont gamme livrée comme
on disait tout à l'heure alors voulait
pas devenir musicien comme aux parents
puis en juin distribution de prix et
vous jouez labit merveilleux d'andersen
et là vous enfant timide est enfin
heureux et les adultes se taisent devant
vous et là vous dit peut-être mais je
fais du théâtre que pour ça c'est pour
les habitudes ce test devant moi
finalement les gens m'écoutent
ça a été le déclic c'était le déclic oui
et
mais après il ya des évènements
extraordinaires je pourrais vous dire
que maintenant les gens se taisent
encore quand je le dis à mon métier pas
toujours une fois mais taille d'une
chose d'extraordinaire joe dassin tout
petit théâtre minuscule une pièce de jeu
ne me souviens plus le nom de l'auteur
et le spectateur qui était comme ça
appuyé sur la scène chez me passionnant
très gentiment l objet parle j'avais
parlé pendant 10 minutes tout seul me
dit ça doit pas être marrant de grâce à
tous les soirs c'est terrible mais
l'action avec une telle gentillesse mais
que la compassion
il m'encourageait presse on va pas faire
tout autre carrière parce qu'on y sera
encore demain matin mais bon 64 bunuel
j'en ai d'une femme de chambre 66 belle
de jour catherine deneuve 67
vous êtes monsieur dame dans les
demoiselles de rochefort vous adorez
benjamen de ville est alors en 69 moi je
m'en souviens à l'époque j'en ai un peu
voulu vous prenez un virage c'est à dire
que vous aviez cette espèce de carrière
très brillante et tout ça vous fait
dillinger est mort de marco ferreri et
là je dois dire moi je m'en souviens je
vous en ai un peu voulu dire mais
pourquoi ils continuent pas en l'aiment
tellement comme ça mais pourquoi il va
faire ces petits films qu'on n'arrive
pas bien à comprendre
oui mais alors je sais comment il a
voulu parce que avant je représente l
homme de quarante voilà de bonne tenue
voilà exacte et rigaud et l'intelligence
voilà et puis tu craques je suis passé
voilà vers une sorte de pas de voyous
mais de détraqués c'est ça du thème rock
de par aldo il ya comme ça mais moi
j'avais pas envie de faire une carrière
avec une image
ouais lice il lisse immeuble alors
appris la grande bouffe en 73 ans la
veuve est réussie parce que c'était vous
êtes fait huer sur les marges de
l'ancien d'aller à jarry soi-disant
gâcher ma carrière votre mère a pas
voulu voir le film non votre belle mère
n'en parlons pas non je crois pas je
veux c'est votre beau-père je crois
qu'ils étaient plutôt lisse allez encore
me croisent votre belle-mère été comme
bodmer c'est énorme mon beau père était
oui en secret c'est un super scandale
effectivement là vous êtes devenu
effectivement vous étiez un artiste
honorables comme vous disiez vous êtes
devenu un peu lent vous êtes traité à
l'époque de la grande bouffe on vous
traiter de sale [ __ ] de communistes
enfin c'était vraiment bien un ami à moi
dont je tairai le nom mais très
gentilles un moment on a dit que le
bruit courait que j'étais homosexuel à
l'époque encore c'était mal vu
oui heureusement ça a changé oui je le
verse du ne suis toujours pas oui
maintenant vaut mieux la fmh est pas bon
on verra
et qu'est ce que voulait dire je ne sais
plus a dit mme écoutez c'est normal
parce qu'il fait des choses tellement
bizarre oui c'est normal qu'ils soient
au moose exclus comme si on pouvait
faire des choses bizarres de là dans la
vie que kan était homosexuel alors il ya
remercia le café une bio de boucher
france empire et ça s'appelle d'ailleurs
espère michel piccoli le provocateur
donc il ya un moment au début des 70
cette volonté de sortir de votre rôle
pour pour aller vers des films plus
difficile des films plus risqués oui
j'ai jamais eu envie de m'installer dans
une carrière avec des rails
brillant tout le temps j'ai envie de
bouger de de découvrir d'essayer
d'autres choses
marquer et ça vous a bien conservée
parce que là je dis pas votre âge vous
le vieux succès
vous êtes né en 25 100 blagues attention
27 décembre oui ce sont néanmoins vous a
conservé de choisir le ce côté comme ça
non ça vous pensez oui bien sûr ça donne
une énergie là oui c'est vital soissons
mois 600 km 75 ans on se re retrouvent
pour notre rendez-vous critique théâtre
avec notre fameux duo tragi-comique
philippe tesson jacques nerson et on
commence avec le misanthrope de molière
mise en scène de jean pierre miquel avec
alberte aveline michel favory denis
podalydès clotilde de bayser à la
comédie-française bonheur à vous
commencez le pitch le misanthrope
est ce utile ah oui c'est utile c'est
l'intellectuel se dit que ce sont les
pièces connues sur le moins connu bien
sûr
j'aurai plus de 10 en europe je pense
qu'il ya un peu de téléspectateurs de re
histoire rive gauche qui n'ont pas vu de
80 ans une fois dans leur vie
le pitch club comment on pourrait dire
la clcc célimène c'est à dire ô combien
il est difficile pour un homme sincère
des mères une femme coquette un genre
qui s'appelle alceste et qui est très
amoureux d'une dame dont on ne sait pas
très bien si elle aime ou si elle ne
l'aiment pas si elle est sincère ou si
elle est vraiment coquette celle et
frivole ou si elle est grave elle est
tout à la fois et on sait et j'ai
beaucoup bm c'est un conte elle les
voiles à l'est mais j'y vois un pg la
fin alors qu'elle était une femme libre
puisqu'elle est veuve donc à cette
époque c'est le seul statut qui donne à
une femme une entière liberté de choix
elle choisit d'être sa femme c'est lui
qui ne veut plus c'est lui qui ne veut
pas c'est lui qui ne veut plus part j'ai
le tort par saba ça c'est votre avis il
ya le père santa claus de bayser qui
joue le roulé à cause des conditions
elle posté à oui mais elle pose quand
même abaisser la beauce a beau être
utile de 2006 et elle mange que des
conditions elle dit que je t'adore mais
j'irai pas la campagne non mais ça chez
lui mais c'est lui qui veulent alors je
veux poser des conditions c'est lui qui
dit je vais vous emmener dans un désert
bah oui il est évident que cette femme
qui est jeune qui a 20 ans n'a pas envie
de finir ses jours à la campagne la
campagne de l'époque c'est quand même
pas très très marrant c'est un peu ce
qu'on prend et c'est vrai moi je lui
donne entièrement réservé en plus mal
ils doivent enfin gilles lerouge nous
fait vous n'êtes pas en train de nous
faire un label car elle a saisi la belle
carey a pas d'accord chacun a la sienne
match j'en faisais de caser les enfants
et clotilde de bayser kim admirable
touchante et on ne peut que donner tord
asle cesse dans des conditions pareilles
non mais ça j'aime pas moindre assez
considérions je ne prends pas parti moi
je veux je me décide à jouer au théâtre
je me mets quand même pas je suis pas un
adolescent est ce qu'on ne fait pas la
plage de sète
je vais c'est pas celle là où j'étais
pas au bon non non non non j'essaie
d'être le plus honnête plus froid le
plus objectif vas-y moi je ne dis pas qu
est ce que je ferai à 13 à 16 soit la
raison à latence est un hymen on ne dit
pas ça je dis qu'elle est merveilleuse
dans ce que vous dites d'ailleurs c'est
à dire dans cette ambivalence dans cette
incertitude dans cette gravité légère
dans cette légèreté grare et elle est
par ailleurs et j'ai beaucoup aimé lui
aussi contrairement à beaucoup de med-v
qu'on ferait peut-être déjà tout pas on
n'en a pas parlé lui aussi j'ai beaucoup
aimé damman j'ai toujours eu un faible
pour denis podalydès dont j'aime
beaucoup la lieu général silhouette la
façon d'être dans la vie d'être sur la
scène est très touché mes cheveux qui
sera bien jeune et c'est bien de voir
nice est jeune car après tout on en voit
beaucoup plus cadrage souvent des
quadragénaires et des types de 20 ans il
est encore il est encore fragile tapeux
boutonneux ça il est encore adolescent
est encore en fait n'est recensée
clotilde de bayser et vous c'est denis
podalydès et les deux mois chez moi je
suis les deux je fais pas le détail
c'est un très beau couple célimène al 16
l'un des plus rafraîchissants des plus
anciens et des plus vrai que ça je
serais tentée d'être d'accord avec
philippe je devrais quand même ajouter
quelque chose c'est que ce spectacle qui
a beaucoup de qualités il faudrait aussi
parler notamment de michel favory que je
trouve oronte très touchant c'est une
nouvelle interprétation du rôle je
trouve vraiment émouvant et arsinoé
riddick arsinoé parfaitement ridicule
joué par alberta en scène de façon très
très vieille comédie française mais ce
qui est drôle
à propos de ce spectacle c'est que c'est
en fait un spectacle rigoureusement
plastique et même académique à ceci près
que jean pierre miquel ne veut surtout
pas avoir l'air académique
sinon il va se faire traiter de ringard
donc il fait faire à leurs questions un
décor avec huawei sur atouts des
costumes grotesque grotesque alors
notamment qu'est ce qui fait ici mais au
18e sur des pantalons d'aujourd'hui
c'est d'une led de que vous ne pouvez
pas être juste m'en excuser moi jacques
c'est ce que je voulais vous demander
bon on a parlé de la pièce bon tout le
monde connaît évidemment le misanthrope
connaissez mieux avant parce que ça
passe et la télé à 20h30 en noir et
blanc
vous avez parlé d'interprétation de
podalydès et buzzer alors commencer
justement alors les costumes le décor
voilà c'est ça est-ce que
l'interprétation de mickey l'ont fait il
ya une direction d'acteurs qui paraît
assez hétérogène puisque encore une
foire signer n'est pas convaincante
alors qu al ccc lima 2 et alors qu'elle
est là qu est ce qui revient
jean pierre miquel on ne sait jamais
très bien ça qu'est ce qui reviendrait
bien distribués oui il a bien dit c'est
vrai en revanche l'environnement
scénique et notamment le décor et les
costumes sur tout à fait contestable
mais finalement on lui pardonne parce
que qu'est-ce que c'est le misanthrope
c'est là des plus sublimes dialogues
d'audiard rencontre entre un homme et
une femme on lui pardonne non on ne peut
pas dont je m'assois essentiel et jean
lui pardonne pas ça mais effectivement
les sens et ça reste un spectacle hors
maintenant la question donc les nerfs
sony steve ont les nerfs sony steve ont
notamment pour les acteurs et pour cette
justesse de distribution d'été sony
style vivant pour la même raison
bien que nous avons réconcilier donc tu
es ce nist les nerfs cenis alors
maintenant on va passer à la
comédie-française toujours grimbert avec
la pièce la mort de tambours de mise en
scène de jean michel ribes avec yves
gasc ciment n claire vernet roland
bertin thierry hancisse les jambières
michael et c'est jacques nerson qui
commence bel l'orangerie réussi ou pas
d'abord non entraînons réussi parce
qu'on a loupé le coche parce que c'était
probablement pas par cette pièce qu'il
fallait commencer
il aurait fallu que la comédie française
et davantage de réflexes et qu'elle
fasse entrer l'atelier dont nous avons
beaucoup parlé avant dernier mais qui a
été monté par ader privé et aussi par le
centre dramatique de marseille par
gildas bourdet et là ils prennent une
pièce qui est loin d'être le meilleur de
grumberg qui est une pièce de jeunesse
qui a été créée je crois en 71
j'avais assisté à la création c'était
déjà la comédie française je crois
qu'ils jouaient la pièce mais c'était à
l'odéon alors l'événement c'est que ça
rentre au répertoire enfin franchement
cette seconde
le pitch le pitch c'est l'histoire
effectivement du troisième reich qui
soit de hitler mais vue et racontée à
travers une allégorie vaguement
shakespearienne
on est entre ubu et mac beth et
puisqu'on parle de mcb est
malheureusement pour grumberg un an
après la création d'un mort de tabou en
72 à l'alliance française
il y avait un certain ionesco qui
faisait jouer macbett et c'est le même
projet et il est 100 fois plus réussi
d'abord parce que la langue de ionesco
est beaucoup plus belle beaucoup plus
serré beaucoup plus drus que celle de
grumberg dans ce spectacle
et j'ajouterais quand même une petite
chose c'est que le spectacle souffre
d'être monté avec trop de moyens
c'est un spectacle qui passeraient
beaucoup mieux dans un cabaret monter ou
à café théâtre monte avec des
accessoires pêcher un peu partout et là
tout est très appuyé les que les
costumes sont magnifiques et ses rails
cette splendeur se retourne contre la
pièce qui est encore qu'au les gers
voilà la pièce est un peu trop légère
pour supporter d'aller offre cet apparat
monsieur philippe tesson s'il vous
sépare cette pièce qu'il fallait
commencer
c'est par cette pièce que devait entrer
jean claude grumberg à la comédie
française
il y était déjà entrée parmi les jeunes
hauteur 170 skritts ou d'usagé dit ça
n'est pas par cette pièce qu'il fallait
commencer je vous réponds c'est par
cette pièce qu'il fallait commencer
c'est une pièce qui n'est peut-être pas
être bien c'est pas une pièce de
maturité donc c'est vrai qu'elle a elle
a des défauts de désordre notamment et
de complaisance mais c'est une pièce
superbe
c'est une pièce super par sa force
théâtrale et ce par le message qu'elle
diffuse même message que yonath couronné
six marines et c'est normal shakespeare
a également diffusé le message de
ionesco et d'autres que lui veulent mais
vous savez il n'y a pas beaucoup de
messages apportant à diffuser et sait
très bien que le théâtre diffusent des
messages les plus jeunes rats et la
noise âge là à temps et je termine si
vous si vous permettez
c'est une très belle pièce est un texte
très forte dont la symbolique encore une
fois est une symbolique grave dramatique
contemporaine et universel c'est à dire
la barbarie dont le traitement est
superbe parce que rodez comme comme il
le dit lui-même grabherr exorcise le
désespoir par le rire et ses données à
très peu d'auteurs dramatiques
c'est donc je maintiens par cette pièce
qu'il fallait commencer d'autre part on
est on était en attente très forte il y
avait grabherr mais il y avait aussi un
metteur en scène qu'on aime beaucoup que
vous avez reçus ici il ya une complicité
entre grabherr et rip qui s'était
exprimé à travers ce spectacle on l'a vu
l'an dernier au complexe appelé rêvait
peut-être il ya le même la même
fantaisie la même invention le même
génie le même humour chéri mais chez
grabherr et enfin le spectacle est
absolument somptueux les trois éléments
beaucoup trop
la réussite sont la malheureuse mari si
je suis absolument d'accord avec jacques
c'est trop somptueux très plein de fric
ça des gorges de fric de falbalas de 2,2
de décors de costumes d'accessoires chez
c'est à une norme et chaqra de la pièce
on se retrouve après les pubs pour la
suite de ce best of est notre agenda du
week-end programmée par mes amis de
toujours
je reçois maintenant le comédien michel
galabru pour monsieur amédée au théâtre
comédia michel galabru bonsoir bonsoir
alors l'histoire c'est simple c'est
amédée un prof de français vous prof de
français à la retraite qui rencontre une
prostituée qui se retrouvent patron de
bordel voilà le pitch comme on dit ici
le l'argument comme on disait avant est
très simple et c'est un prix mais c'est
une très bonne situation parce que le
comique au fond c'est le type qui est
placée malgré lui dans une situation
ce professeur qui est un type très très
jeune est très quotidien très français
moyen est brusquement projeté dans un
milieu qu'il ne connaît pas et devient
macro s'il le sait le le contraire de ce
qu'il est alors ça ça ressort comique
effectivement très très puissant et
c'est vrai les gens moi j'ai vu la pièce
les gens rient toutes les 30 secondes
c'est l'incroyable oui et d'ailleurs
quand vous dites ils ont tourné pour
l'école des femmes
les gens venez vous demandez mais quand
est-ce que vous reprenez monsieur amédée
c'est quand même extraordinaire de jouer
avec l'article un grand classique et les
gens vous dire ce qu'ils avaient bien
rigolé puis que bon le classique ça
n'intéresse pas tout le monde est là
c'est quelquefois alors je me suis
intéressé à votre vie pour savoir un peu
comment ces interviews portraits et
savoir comment vous étiez devenu michel
galabru alors votre père était directeur
du port de safi au maroc et vous avez
une enfance plutôt heureuse
les premières années de votre vie vous
étiez la marche je n'ai pas trop à
l'école il y avait un grand noir ctp de
vous que s'appeler mahjoub et vous avez
une vie plutôt plutôt sympa votre père
était été dur avec vous c'est ça qui
vous a peut-être laissé ce trac cette
espèce de toujours et peut-être
regretter chrome était autrefois les
parents
la plupart dans certaine bourgeoisie il
était gentil s'était des braves gens
mais il était sévère et qui seraient les
couleurs et vous savez autrefois les
classes étaient très séparés il y avait
la classe ouvrière ethiquable et du pain
alors maintenant le pain ou le gaspille
on en mange pas et puis la classe
bourgeoise moyenne et puis alors il y
avait la classe riche et quand on était
dans la classe bourgeoise les parents
avait toujours peur que d'une déchéance
à dire que c'est de travailler de tes
mains sales ouvriers monfils maintenant
conscience maintenant ça existe le
présent - parce que quand vous avez un
plombier qui vous pour mille francs pour
réparer votre chasse d'eau et que vous
avez un docteur qui vous prend 150
francs ouais bon et c'est plus la même
chose non mais c'est vrai que votre père
voulait pas nous c'est les comédiens et
quand vous avez fait le matamore vision
comique il a eu un malaise
enfin société me voyant dans le costume
de matam
alors après vous allez voir vous quittez
le match le père dirige est donc
apparemment des portes et vous avez vos
arbres et là alors vous première
déception l'école j'étais viré cette
fois est la première référence à guitry
quai pour vous quelqu'un d'extrêmement
important vous dit c'est pas grave moi
j'étais viré cette fois guitry est
évident est de 12 fois en importance de
guitry pour vous c'est c'est colossal
puisque vous étiez petit voulu d'abord
être footballeur lui est michèle seiler
et puis après chauffeur de car et puis
après vous dit j'étais sacha guitry
oui je n'ai jamais été moi même dans la
rue ça continue un peu je n'aime pas
tellement oui parce que c'est normal je
suis enfoncé dans le quotidien dans ma
personne qui par la fréquentation que
j'aurais est courante et banale le
m'intéresse m'a dit aussi que vous avez
un physique qui ressemble pas à votre
mental en fait non je suis un dur et
donc c'est vrai que vous habitez un
corps différent de voilà voilà
alors vous êtes tellement ressembler à
guitry que vous étiez des bagues pour
faire comme lui enfin bon votre premier
nom de théâtre c'était michel livry vous
portiez les mêmes costumes d'étudier les
mêmes pensées même écrivain est alors le
goût du théâtre vous est venue à
montpellier quand une de vos tentes vous
a fait écouter un disque de guitry et 10
25 ans a été le l'amour masqué et puis
de bureau narry de bureaux et les parcs
des virades des trucs comme ça parce que
j'entendais ça tout le temps
ouais et je continue à les écouter a
même curieux vous écoutez guîtres et oui
alors après vous avez le bac vous a
quand même essayé cinq fois avant de
l'avoir et la boue votre père vous
fassiez du doigt mais vous mentez à
paris votre père et vous avez dit un
truc terry vous avez dit je veux que tu
travailles au contentieux chez schneider
j'imagine ce que ça a dû vous faire or
je le savais pas ce que ça voulait dire
et ça m'a paru il a été maladroit parce
qu'il ne pouvait pas trouver à terme
plus rébarbatifs c'était les comptes ans
gates il se l'est vers moi et je dis
j'aurais échoué complètement riches et
des ah c'était le creusot ouais c'est
dire si le thé le baron empain qui a
pris la succession du père est traître
parce que je n'ai des rêves en irlande
et bien sûr alors après vous partez à
paris alors là une espèce de caen vous
quitter l'endroit où vous habitez votre
frère fait la quête vous vendez votre
fono votre collection de timbres monter
à paris votre mère pleure votre père pas
content il lève la créa l'unsa il n'est
pas très content et vous arrivez à paris
donc c'est un peu rastignac d'ancash
d'avis à ce moment là ben je vais avoir
à 24 secondes de course avec 3 1 3 1
au début c'est pas drôle vous êtes
contrôleurs au tnp et puis un jour il ya
ces gens pignol devant l'église la
madeleine qui commençait cette
révélation de il vous a dit vous êtes
comique et vous avez dit dans ma famille
seraient les gens sont drôles comment ça
s'est passé
oui oui c'est bénéfique ça c'est le
petit déclic
il m'a dit c'est curieux c'est devant
l'église à baden - bonjour d'été dans un
court le cours donné 10 days c'était le
lead in health était un personnage doyen
des maires à 15 heures heure française
c'était un grand bonhomme ratu je suis
très reconnaissant et pignol était un
ami intime vous avez connu à montpellier
c'est moi qui le donnait le goût du
théâtre il après il a apprêté
réalisateur à la télévision mais cela et
nous étions donc élèves et il m'a dit
c'est curieux quand même parce que ta
famille et drôle ton père est drôle
moi je trouve pas mon père tel rôle
apparemment j'avais plutôt peur et il
m'a dit eh toi c'est curieux pourquoi tu
y es puis trolls dans la vie et puis sur
scène tu devrais chercher là dedans il a
eu raison de le faire chercher dans les
très acide great dans l'origine
j'ai écouté mon père parlait ouais voilà
pour la première fois j'ai entendu des
choses des bruits avoir de drôles donc
rôle dans l'intonation en 50 et en fait
votre premier film qui s'appelle ma vie
ma femme ma vache et moi je vous avoue
je connais pas le film de jan de weghe
et 20 ans plus tard donc vous aura fallu
vingt ans vingt ans plus tard je dis ça
parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse dans
les villes et carrière c'est l'espèce
d'abnégation et de d'entêtement qu'il
faut c'est dire que j'ai mis vingt ans
entre 51 71 ans 71
vous faites le viager et avec tchernia
quel premier film finalement ou là on
dit attends galabru s'est pas seulement
à un comique comme ça et tout s'est
passé est un grand acteur et alors après
vous avez fait section spéciale costa
gavras le juge et l'assassin de taverny
tout le monde connaît avec noiret et
puis parallèlement la série des
gendarmes c'est dire que vous êtes
toujours est passé d'un d'un genre à
l'autre non mais c'est à dire que j'ai
fait les gendarmes avant oui
pour résumer tout ce que vous dites il
ya un critique dans le jeu lui dis moi
je crois que c'est pierre billard donc
que critiquer pineau d'éminents ils amis
et je me rappelle que cette vitrine avis
le génie de taviani et d'avoir trouvé
dans le ringard du gendarme
ouais sont là ça bah oui voilà ça c'est
de savoir ce que ça résume un peu l'état
d'esprit c'est vrai de 2 des gens du
cinéma
alors vous avez 200 films alors on vous
dit toujours que dans un interview la
télé vous avez fait des navets vous
dites oui évidemment je vais évidemment
parce que j'avais des pensions
alimentaires à payer j'avais des impôts
comme tout le monde qui a les femmes
aussi non si mal j oui enfin tout ce
qu'ils écoutent
vous avez écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
je les ai perdus au 18 mai et comment on
fait si votre virginité dans vous parlez
et la fille s'appelait muna c'est
extraordinaire parce que vous avez pris
une prostituée qui avait une montre pour
être sûr de rentrer les cours de maths
quelques histoires d'hiver c'est que
j'ai retrouvé le fils de cette personne
c'est fou rire dès qu un garçon charmant
qui fait du théâtre mon fils de mouna
mais il n'est pas il est pas mona il est
pas il n'est pas professionnel il fait
du théâtre amateur à montpellier on me
l'a présenté c'est à montpellier malin
quand elle vous dit va faire ta petite
toilette venez vous
les pieds et ça extraordinaire a raison
mais c'est marrant de vous voir là vous
êtes plutôt souriant plutôt de bonne
humeur pourtant souvent vous êtes un peu
dépressif un peu que vous êtes très
lucide je m'efforce à la lucidité et à
l'objectivité ce qui est par kobo
d'avoir tout ce que jamais d'ailleurs on
y parvient jamais mais moi je suis si
peu timide je veux passer d'un centime à
le faire aujourd'hui la 9e riz complet
ou à l'abattement est de taille
ça dure c'est très bien mais en plus
vous souffrez pas de votre âge parce que
je me sens jeune dans une vieille
voiture mais vous dis je me sens jeanne
où vous avez page pas que vous avez on
peut le dire non on ne peut pas se dire
d'accord n'agira pas alors je dis pas ça
ne ce n'est pas de se préciser
on a l'âge de sa mort serait dire que
tant jobourg ailleurs pour dire il était
vieux pas avant est-ce que dernière
question
est-ce que vous des fois vos angoisses
ne viennent pas du fait que finalement
vous me croyez pas je ne croyais pas en
dieu vous dit s'il existe c'est pas un
brave homme ce n'est pas très gentil
pour lui et oui mais c'est pas gentil
pour nous parce que quelqu un qu ils ont
dit avoir bon c'est peut-être un peu
puéril ce que je dis et primaire enfin
on n'a pas de réponse
les dates ou créer c'est tout il voit
tout il a tout créé tout tout tout tout
à les sentiments entre et regarder dans
la merde
quelque 120 avec des maladies effrayant
qui va aider cette petite boule et la
terre qu'il a infesté de microbes
qu'elle des cécités telle nécessité s'il
était tout puissant de faire ça voudrait
une réponse
et comme disait sacha guitry à bas est
ce que vous croyez
il est le moindre signe serait le
bienvenu à la balance est formidable en
fait ma chute c'est ce que voulait la
moindre forme il va très loin
chers amis chers ennemis pour bien
employé votre week-end sortez vous
cultiver mais avant d'éteindre votre
télé écouter rda rejet elizabeth
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait ce week end
alors moi j'ai sorti les grands moyens
c'est bien vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
aller au cinéma puisque je vous offre
des places et que j'ai été chez american
le tibet lamouri affiche une supposée
vous a pas de céder 3 alors beauty
incontournable à cause de kevin
spéciales es2 annette bening
insupportable et merveilleuse et grandit
le côté absurde et grotesque en rôle
d'épousé de kevin spéciaux dans un film
qui est une satire donc sur cet american
way of life qui se lézarde et que les
américains qui sont malins et pervers
dans le cinéma et dans le système
hollywoodien aime tant attaquer
autrement dit comme un s'auto flageller
avec talent honnêtement sérieusement
vous y allez accès avant même d'écouter
ce que vont nous conseiller nos amis
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire rêver
de voir belles à mourir et la mairie
alors je vais peut-être ajouté fisher
mais l'amour et ans parce qu'il y à un
sujet qui vous est cher ce sont les
musées leur élection
et puis parce que encore une fois c'est
le film quasiment complémentaire de
américaine bourgade au pouvoir les deux
et là on a hot leader mais peut-être
pour le lendemain
après le brunch sera forcément grand
breton pour cause de sujets ou un petit
curie vous allez voir fish and chips qui
est non mais je vous jure je le redis je
réitère et j'insiste et je persiste et
je signe une formidable
10 sur une famille mais une famille avec
un pas qui mal et une anglaise femelles
et leurs jeunes rejetons qui veulent
s'intégrer
je ne vais pas au festival du court
métrage en ce temps là je vais suicide
et berlingo tant que c'est que des
berlingots fait voir donc c'est à
clermont ferrand je vais voir les cieux
métrage voilà du 4 au 12 février donc ça
démarre le 4 et voilà
et c'est quand même outre que c'est le
plus grand festival de courts métrages
du moins c'est une ville sinistrée
réponse est donnée de trois conseillers
comme ça moi je connais bien clermont
ferrand je suis désolé pour mes amis
clermontois non non non non ne
m'inquiète pas sur la vie ne nous serons
consciencieux vous serez voilà et jern
voilà idiot mais le week-end voilà je
vais me retourner et voilà est en face
de moi j'ai patrice carmouze et si on
faisait rien ce week end à faire on
pourrait faire ou alors on pourrait
faire un bon saut de coupe dominique
voynet c'est quoi l'histoire du bon sens
je ne sais pas l'agenda béton qui sépare
les jeunes on s'en fout alors c'est non
voilà l avez dit vous savez pourtant
pendant qu'il ya eu la tempête de tout
ça qu'elle était un colloque à la
réunion j'ai passé et le meriva s'est
très vite et l'express nous dit
aujourd'hui après l'été ensuite en
vacances à l'île maurice
et alors ça aurait pu passer une
personne vous savez qui a cafté non
chirac après le conseil des ministres
étaient dire ça jospin qu'est ce que
vous pensez à paris cannes joue je suis
d'accord c'est la 120e du fil à la patte
vous savez de feydeau wave dans la mise
en scène d'alain saxe avec pas d'acteurs
connus et ça prouve que ça marche très
très bien c'était un pari de le faire
c'est aller au théâtre de la porte
saint-martin donc a laissé un très bon
de faire le boulot des sens la liste est
encore piquer le boulot des sceaux pour
dire que patrick chesnais remplace
didier sandre dîner entre amis à la
comédie des champs-elysées puis ça vous
avec catherine frot à l'ats catherine
vautrin la chesnaie savez très bien
aussi
et puis deux idées de week-ends vite
fait parce que il ya alors est-ce un
m'intéresse dit des villes où vit le
mieux est de la vidéo et demi en france
paraît-il que ces unions alors on peut
aller à lyon ouais bien faire de bonne
bouffe sur les canadiens et alors et
dans l'express de départements où vit le
mieux c'est la vendée donnerait ce qu'on
peut aller vers des rochefort tellement
voulait pas voir le musée pierre loti et
puis et puis vous allez de wazemmes si
philippe me l'avez vous l'avez souffler
merci patrice et là je vais me retourne
et je me vois là et c'est plus la magie
c'est philippe tesson qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qui se passe ce week-end eh
ben je vais à rochefort puisqu'ils me le
dit d'y aller
c'est vrai que c'est très bon roche
blessé j'ai vu les demoiselles
ah non mais de la ville est superbe tu
vis l'étranger avec justement on aurait
pu en parler hier avec un centre ancien
qui est très très bien restaurer avec
des petites maisons une atmosphère très
douce et puis la maison de pierre loti
que t'as que merrill était copieux dame
bon alors alors nous combien il m'a pris
la main plat blâme à la pâte
april a pas de fille dont il a eu raison
d'ailleurs parce que c'est vraiment très
très bien c'est encourager et très drôle
en théâtre de spectacles de 21h vous
verrez après pourquoi jeudi de 21h
un spectacle très grasse 113 enlevé très
dynamique c'est mort accidentelle d'un
anarchiste labruyère de dario fo avec un
comédien époustouflant qui s'appelle
jean jacques moreau voix c'est pour
vraiment pour cesser roboratif si on me
disait l'autre jour on en parle avec mes
garçons qu'en fait on comprend pourquoi
elle a eu ce prix nobel de la paix a
fait sourire un peu mais quand on voit
ce genre de pierre tout à fait tout à
fait c'est vraiment un des grands
comiques du xxème siècle dario qu'à ses
intérêts la bruyère chez notre ami
meldegg eric fry et puis jeanne j'y
reviens parce que ça dure plus pendant
huit dixièmes collins à jeanne à l'aco
league alors là la colline pour pour
s'émouvoir parce que c'est très bruyant
trois comédiennes sublime jeune de peggy
on en a parlé vous vous rappelez j'exige
me suivent avec des médias c'est comme
ça et puis alors j'avais dit à deux
spectacles d'un tuner parce que moi je
conseille aussi je trouve c'est une
heure très agréable pour le spectacle
19h30
oui ça dure une heure il ya comme ça
deux trois spectacles on en parlera
peut-être un peu la semaine prochaine
mais tout de suite je recommande
je ne sais pas si vous voulez mais moi
j'ai un faible pour cette femme c'est
judith magre ben oui je crois qu'on doit
l'invité et elle a un rôle en or dans
charlie pièces américaines
elle joue une femme méchante agressive
paumé mais en même temps plein deux
pénos à auron point des champs elysées
dans la petite salle s'appelle la salle
jean wauthier merci philippe à lundi
elle a dit je me retourne et là ô
stupeur patrice carmouze patrice carraud
quand ça va
alors les flyers à l'ensilage et on
rigole plus là bas maintenant on en même
temps je me dis c'est idiot de dire aux
gens de sortir
il ferait mieux de faire l'amour avec la
personne n'allait pas faire l'amour à
rentrant il peut faire l'amour quand
d'ex moins bien c'est bien choisir entre
l'amour et les sorties fait voir bon
alors gg la prozac prozac tracks night
au gibus au gibus vous donner l'adresse
parce que c'est vous qui l'avez même
menacé 18 rue du faubourg du temple à
paris dans le rouge mais surtout très
important et ça eric dahan ne me
démentirait pas s'il était là elle à
haus of legends à l'enfer 34 rue du
départ avec ce magnifique flyers house
of legends avec tout un tas de dj
extrêmement prestigieux via un art du
flyer quand on en a vraiment c'est un
des arts les plus magnifiques fresques
et puis alors il ya des des nouveaux la
el toro je suis parce que c'est une
association qui s'appelle el toro et
alors il faut une disco party à la salle
gaveau vous imaginez la salle gabin
salle gaveau et des zags la salle pleyel
va pas très bien géré la salle gaveau
sert à faire des audits voilà ça c'est
tout ça et samedi soir salle et tout ça
chez vous et du pot to say samedi soir
je pense qu'il faut commencer par la
disco ensuite le prozac et puis après
viens là où seuls les jeunes
non ça non mais on en mange quoi
dimanche le mal de la ram mal de mal à
la tête
donc un brin aspirine 2 voilà et puis ce
regard d'un américain sur davos au
vitriol c'est un journaliste new-yorkais
extrêmement dandy et qui raconte à quel
point les maîtres du monde
ouais perdre leur temps dans cette
station donc samedi soir donc déconnade
avant l'amour là et là dimanche
intelligent oui mais intelligence très
comique grec tandis qu'en ces énormes
foutage de gueule d'un américain sur les
américains mais les gens moi les gens me
disent on écoute ce que vous dites dans
votre agenda du week-end et depuis qu'on
fait ce que vous dites
on est heureux mais ce qu' ils nous
obéissons raymond doille j'obéis
salindres avaient tous les spectateurs
obéissent à ce qu'on dit
ils s'en sont contents ils saint geours
vote jean toi jean laloux toujours dit
je pense qu'ils obéissent plus athées
sont qu'à moi c'est non
voilà le best-of de rive droite rive
gauche c'est fini chers amis chers
ennemis bon week-end et à lundi 19h30
pour notre heure et demie quotidienne
d'exception culturelle télévisuelle et
là je vais dire voilà je veux dire pas
vécu ça va s'arrêter
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus